just about ready for baseball here at
lone depot park it's the first of three
between the mets and the marlins and
edward cabrera gets the ball it'll be
his third big league start and the
second one in this building
and he walks vr to start this game a 3-2
change-up
and the mids of a lead-off base runner
so here's alonzo in his 30th home run
yesterday to give the mets a lead that
held up until the ninth inning
and alonzo rockets one a deep left
center field forget that that is way out
of here
pete alonso his 100th career home run
number 31 of the year two run shot for
alonso he's homered in back-to-back
games he's hit triple digits for his
career
second fastest to 100 home runs in major
league history only ryan howard got
there faster than
pete's 347 games to reach that plateau
ground ball to jazz at short
makes the play over to first and the
inning is over but pete alonso goes deep
and it's one two nothing mess as the
marlins go up against carlos carrasco
for the second straight time yeah his
last start was against the marlins five
in the third three runs like rich hill
looking for his first win in a mets
uniform three balls and two strikes from
carrasco is grounded to second it's
actually gonna be lindor cutting over
but jazz beats it out slow roller and
they were played back and that speed of
jazzy gets to top speed within about two
steps
and another base hit this one toward the
left center field gap jazz is on his way
to third he should get there easily de
la cruz takes an aggressive turn
and gets back marlins are set up first
and third cesar sanchez to the
dish and that is a base hit into right
field that will score jazz easily de la
cruz gets to second in rbi for sanchez
and the marlins are down the run de la
cruz at second sanchez at first still
nobody out
and brinson goes down swinging for the
first down he just pounded brenson
inside down and in and it looks like
brinson has a big hole in his swing
right there this was a change up right
running yep change up down and in
brought him to his knees
now joe panic
and he drives one out to center going
back pillar way back and pilar runs it
down what a play
kevin pillar getting a chance to play
the position that he has excelled at for
years and he makes a tremendous play to
run down that drive by panic for the
second out two another diaz
and it's pulled on the ground into the
shift baez is there
side retired so carrasco limits the
first inning damage to one run helped
out by a great play by kevin pillard
what is behind home plate uh that would
be spongebob
oh is that a cinnamon toaster it's a
cinnamon toast crunch gary how can you
tell the difference oh you love the
cereal i'm sure it'll be looking that
one all night long eddie alvarez to lead
things off
two and two on alvarez that one hit to
second but it's actually the shortstop
lindor and alvarez is aboard that's had
the shift on right at lindor but
couldn't make the play
and again the butcher boy and that is a
fair ball into the corner
here comes alvarez around third he's
gonna score and edward cabrera ties the
game
well i know somebody who's not in favor
of the dh quite yet
this young man can swing the back first
career hit rbi double all of the above
for edward cabrera and it ties the game
of two first and second one out and
alonzo lays off this change up for ball
four so three straight walks now for
cabrera have loaded the bases for
michael conforto
and conforto not hit on the foot and
that will force in a run and the mets
take the lead vr comes in to score the
go-ahead run the fifth base is loaded
hit by pitch for the mets this year so
the bases remain loaded for javi baez
and that's off the batter of the hand it
hit his hand and that'll force in
another run did they ask if he swung
though gary he did not did not swing
that gun let's hope it's not broken
back-to-back bases loaded hit by pitch
make it 4-2 and as soon as you get word
that thompson may be ready might be time
to go to the bullpen here bases remain
loaded for the mets zach thompson coming
in
one-two pitch to mcneil is lifted out to
left field
that's brinson out there he makes the
catch here comes the throw it holds
alonzo
at third base
good strong throw from brinson
groud ball
jazz goes the short way thompson comes
in and limits the damage
leaves the bases loaded
and carrasco delivers that one lined up
the middle of base hit it went back to
that changeup that he struck him out on
and has been uh kind of messing around
with brinson all night long
and a ground ball backhanded by vr he's
got the play to first and it gets by
alonso
brinson goes to third
and the marlins will have runners on the
quarters
so it that that blue bar with those
cameras are i believe it may have hit
that
those are cameras that are set up and
then those would be out of play they
said that donny can challenge the call
if he wanted to and donny
opting to challenge the call
he gets second base so that's exactly
what that was wow now he's sandias who
hit with the bases loaded in the first
and esan with a fly ball out to center
field polar backing up
he'll have room to make the catch but
brinson is going to tag and score alfaro
moves to third and a sac fly for issan
diaz gets the marlins back to within a
run
so that'll bring up eddie alvarez
this one's out toward left center field
pilar giving chase that's gonna get down
and eddie alvarez is gonna get to second
base with an rbi double
and the marlins tie it up at four
now welcome back eddie alvarez
speed has been on display already
tonight
gets himself a 2-1 change-up and stays
on it goes the other way great piece of
hitting
that's crack to deep center field back
goes pillar to the track reaches makes
the catch another gem
from pillar
panic tags and goes to third pillar
putting on a show out there rob panic in
the first inning and now alfaro niels
flight
and he slaps one the other way that's a
base hit
nicely done by mcneil on the change up
away he goes to left field and the mets
have a lead off base runner in the sixth
and zika grounds this one down to first
panic ranging wide
behind the pitcher mcneal though does
not break home
as the ball is swept up by alvarez
and it's too high ball four
so jonathan vr will come to bat with the
bases loaded and one out
one two coming breaking ball hit down to
short bobbled by chisholm
too late to second and the mets take the
lead
a double play ball
and chisholm bobbled it and by the time
he got the throw away smith was in
safely at second across the plate comes
mcneal and it's 5-4 new york bases
remain loaded with one out for lindor
metz now ahead five to four
[Applause]
and lendore lines one in the center
field for a base hit in to score mazika
here comes smith to the plate he will
score
it's a two-run single for francisco
lindor and the mets now late at 7-4
8th inning david pilar leads off against
sean gunther and he pulls one on the
ground right at the shortstop and
chisholm boots another one and that one
got his bare hand here's jd
and he lines this one the other way
that's a base hit that'll go to the
corner guillard his way to third he's
going to be waved around retrieved out
of the corner by sanchez killar scores
on the double by jd davis and the mets
now made it eight to four
first pitch swinging davis lines one the
other way for a pinch head double and
the mets now lead by four
lonzo provided the keynote tonight with
a two run homer in the first inning
and pete sucks one deep left field
headed back toward the back wall that's
out of here
second of the night for pete alonso
101
his 32nd of the year
and he hit the tar end of that ball to
make it nine to four
teeing off boy he loves hitting here
doesn't he
third time this year pizza two in a game
tenth time in his career
joe panic with two outs here in the
ninth inning
and he grounds one down to first alonzo
to castro and the ball game is over
castro works a one two three ninth big
day for alonso with two home runs carlos
carrasco gets his first win as a met and
the mets win a four-hour mess from the
marlins 9-4 to take the opener of this
series